abolishing ice might be one of the most
progressive and attention-grabbing
talking points that's made it onto the
platforms of several midterm election
candidates in 2018 we should protect
families that need our help and that is
not what ice is doing today and that's
why I believe you should get rid of it
start over
reimagine it and build something that
actually works we need to rebuild our
immigration system from top to bottom
starting by replacing ice with something
that reflects our morality and we can
replace it with a humane an agency that
is directed towards faith passage but is
it a realistic demand can ice be
abolished and what does abolishing ice
even mean do we really want to live in a
country where there is this mass force
this mass police force that surveil zazz
every single day and whose job is solely
to hunt immigrants and expel them from
this country hey guys I'm Sonya and this
Sunday we're talking about why there's a
call to abolish a government agency and
what that means for the future of people
in this country both documented and
undocumented
[Music]
in the spring of 2018 news spread about
children being separated from their
parents at the us-mexico border as a
part of the Trump administration
zero-tolerance policy for non-authorized
crossing the United States could not
have an open border to every illegal
alien family and minor on the face of
the earth and it was ice the Immigration
and Customs Enforcement Agency that came
under particular scrutiny eyes detention
facilities have been detailing children
who were separated from their families
by Customs and Border Patrol under the
trompet administration's orders with
horrifying stories of family separation
becoming widespread the call to abolish
ice likewise became widespread now it
might feel like the Immigration and
Customs Enforcement Agency has been
around for a long time but the truth is
you're probably a lot older than the
agency itself after the September 11th
attacks and the declaration of a global
war on terror the George W Bush
administration went into a full
reorganization of governmental agencies
and practices the priority became
so-called counterterrorism a major part
of that reorganization and a major part
of the history of ice was the
introduction of the Department of
Homeland Security the DHS was tasked
with doing whatever it needed to do to
keep the country safe and part of
keeping the u.s. safe was securing its
borders prior to 2003 immigration in the
United States was handled by the
Immigration and Naturalization Service
Agency or I&S which was first under the
Department of Labor and then the
Department of Justice but it was
absorbed into the DHS and doing so made
immigration a matter of national
security to counterterrorism and once it
was absorbed by DHS the IMS was split
into three agencies one was Customs and
Border Protection
another was Citizenship and Immigration
Services and finally Immigration and
Customs Enforcement
aka ice it's worth noting that the
reason why immigration was made such a
big part of the Department of Homeland
Security is because the administration
relied on immigration laws to respond
immediately to the 9/11 attacks attacks
which were carried out by visitors on
short-term visas grace' Martinez deputy
executive director of United We Dream
adds a bit more about the roots of the
agencies that were created after the
attacks they were created out of fear
irrational fear it was based on
Islamophobia and xenophobia which
means like people didn't like Muslims at
that time and they thought that this was
something that they needed to protect
themselves and while ice has a few
different functions its most
controversial function has been the
arresting detaining and deporting of
undocumented immigrants I also have
point out that ice wasn't just big under
the Bush administration it expanded a
lot under the Barack Obama
administration over the course of 13
years its budget increase from three
point three billion dollars to six point
1 billion dollars and the number of
agents and employed tripled today Isis
primary duties arresting detaining and
deporting undocumented immigrants have
caught the attention of a lot of
Americans and that's the springboard for
khalsa polish ice but it's worth noting
that ice didn't start entertaining
families or kids or parents in spring of
2018 the agency has been conducting
raids arrests and detention since it was
first established and for most of its
existence it's been accused of inhumane
unjust an unethical treatment of people
according to the ACLU ice tactics quote
take away even the right to a fair
hearing in court and implicate the
Fourth Amendment's protection against
unreasonable searches and seizures the
counselors our guarantee of due process
and the constitutional guarantee of
equal protection and freedom from
discrimination based on race ethnicity
and national origin a 2018 report put
together by several human rights groups
found that more than half of ice custody
deaths in recent years could have been
prevented with adequate medical care and
attention and the tactics that ice is
renowned for include arresting
undocumented parents after they've
dropped their kids off at school mass
raids picking up anyone anywhere
including in sanctuaries like churches
as well as separating families and
keeping people including kids in cages
Martinez herself remembers what it was
like growing up with the looming fear of
ice that permeated through her
neighborhood I grew up in an
undocumented home I was one four
daughters with two of two undocumented
parents and I've grown up with ice in my
life it's kind of like the boogeyman
of the immigrant community when people
talk about ice
these agents they you imagine like men
and like these green and blue uniforms
coming to your home in the middle of the
day that will separate you from your
family this is something that is
embedded in the culture of immigrants in
this country
Dennis Rivera is a 19 year old
undocumented Houston resident originally
from Honduras and he was detained by ice
for two months maybe a Mundo condom
estuviera no sabía que pasar por que
muchos de Asturias momento escuela is
familia insula momento they're starting
into a movie that Dennis had gone into
an incident with another student at
school and when he went to go report it
the school officer ended up sending him
to a local jail where he was put in
immigration custody then this is Tempest
- it wasn't upon me Familia for the end
he was timing I remove lugar que you
news I don't have romantic hate I'm in
my last yeah okay no Katie I can't make
it
- momento - Sara I go pollo con esta vez
in the preocupado principalmente for
Lima so what does it mean to abolish ice
according to Martinez it means first and
foremost defunding ice but we're
actually asking for right now and what
we need is for these agencies that get
billions of dollars of our tax money to
be defunded for us to take the money
away the money that allows them to have
these cages the money that allows them
to have these detention camps and the
money that allows them to deport people
it's critical to point out that because
the call to abolish ice has been adopted
by so many different people and interest
groups specifically on the wide-ranging
left there's not really an agreement on
what abolishing ice really means for
some it's about restructuring the three
immigration agencies under DHS for
others it's stopping deportations
closing detention centers defunding ice
and Border Patrol and giving asylum to
the undocumented and for others it's
going back to the way things were before
2001 but in an interview with aj+
Alexandra Ocasio Cortez told us that the
problem is
just with the agencies but also with the
underlying ideology that criminalizes
immigrants and immigration from the
get-go when we talk about replacing it
with a system when you talk about really
having a system that is safe that
documents people effectively that is
also not rooted in the discrimination
that our immigration system was
initially built on the first immigration
law in the United States was the Chinese
Exclusion Act the first law about
immigration in the United States was how
do we exclude a specific type of people
and putting immigration under a
department dedicated to countering
terrorism doesn't match up to well the
facts a 2015 study found that immigrants
were way less likely to commit crimes
than those born here the study
emphasized that this also held true for
young undocumented Salvadoran Mexican
and Guatemalan men another study at 2017
one by the Cato Institute found that
undocumented immigrants were 44 percent
less likely to be incarcerated than
those born here and legal immigrants
were 69 percent less likely so there are
two parts to abolishing ice there's the
policy part which may involve getting
rid of the agency or reforming it and
that will be tough to implement without
congressional support then there's a
part to abolishing ice that's undoing
over a century of institutionalized
criminalization of immigrants especially
those crossing the us-mexico border
and for Dennis who just enrolled for
classes at the University of Houston
while his immigration case is ongoing
there's no question about is feature me
mano este pais sinister eyes mis
hermanos amigos mi comida c no x tierra
ninguna de austin de equipo parcei
importable vera casa also the portal oh
so what do you guys think should I speak
about list should it be restructured or
reformed let us know in the comments and
don't forget to Like share and subscribe
and come back next Sunday when we come
at you with another great video